[Música]
y los hospitales en ucrania se han
convertido en los principales objetivos
de la guerra al menos 180 centros
sanitarios han sido atacados a lo largo
de todo el país tenemos reporte de
nuestras enviadas especiales
china celebra su fiesta nacional del
primero de mayo en medio de un aumento
de los contagios de kobe 19 las nuevas
restricciones enmarcadas en la política
de kobe cero que maneja el país marcan
la celebración del día internacional de
los trabajadores
varios detenidos deja la primera jornada
de estado de excepción en ecuador la
medida decretada por el presidente
guillermo lasso en tres provincias del
país busca contrarrestar la violencia
vinculada con las bandas de narcotráfico
tendremos reporte
bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
france 24 6 rodrigo sedano y es un gusto
acompañarlos comenzamos esta emisión en
ucrania en odessa al sur del país
autoridades confirmaron que un bombardeo
ruso destruyó en la pista del aeropuerto
de la urbe portuaria en el mar negro al
tiempo la policía de kiev reportó que
hasta la fecha fueron hallados 1200 dos
civiles muertos por las fuerzas rusas en
la región de kiev en este contexto los
hospitales en ucrania se han convertido
en los principales objetivos de la
guerra nuestras enviadas especiales
irene savio y leticia álvarez viajaron
al frente en un convoy humanitario para
trasladar dos ambulancias a los
hospitales de jarquín
o le exigía al convoy humanitario hacia
jarquín la segunda ciudad más importante
del país y donde la artillería rusa
dispara a diario
este voluntario ucraniano sabe qué
significa trabajar bajo el sonido de los
proyectiles fue uno de los primeros en
evacuar a civiles de la ciudad asediada
de cerca de 15
muchos eran mujeres y niños los llevé
cerca del puente cerca del pin
son dos horas de viaje en las que hay
que pasar por varios checkpoint donde la
ayuda humanitaria se mezcla con
vehículos militares en kharkiv nos
espera se reactive el oncólogo de
radiología jefe del servicio del
hospital este centro es el único que hay
para tratar a todos los enfermos de
cáncer de la región
por desgracia el único dispensario
regional para oncología está dañado y
todos los médicos que trabajan allí lo
dejaron incluso ahora en este centro hay
combates activos y los proyectiles
llegan a esta zona por las consecuencias
de la invasión rusa en ucrania se
reflejan en los hospitales víctor está
el esquí es el director del centro de
salud tienen 100 pacientes de los cuales
sólo 50 pueden recibir radioterapia al
día porque es el máximo que puede
trabajar el aparato necesitan equipos de
tratamiento para todos igualdad primó es
por supuesto por ciento esta máquina
puede ayudar a muchas personas ahora es
la única de este tipo que hay en el
sureste de ucrania
necesitamos muchísimo un acelerador
lineal
sobre miento
alexei tiene 72 años empezó su
tratamiento en plena guerra
es difícil estar enfermo con la guerra
es muy difícil con los medicamentos nos
ayudan desde el oeste de ucrania podemos
hacer pedidos al oeste
markoff es una de las ciudades más
atacadas y bombardeadas desde el inicio
de la invasión rusa como este edificio
de la universidad de la administración
regional todos los días calla artillería
aquí casi todos los días hay heridos y
fallecidos pero los recursos son
limitados y los trabajadores de la salud
que quedan en esta ciudad resisten tan
solo 24 horas después de grabar este
reportaje un hospital muy cercano fue
bombardeado en kharkiv y otro más en
esta guerra donde los sanitarios luchan
por tratar a sus pacientes
la policía israelí llevó a cabo
detenciones se incautó armas después de
que dos hombres armados dispararan y
mataron a un guardia de seguridad en la
entrada de ariel uno de los mayores
asentamientos israelíes en la
cisjordania ocupada tras ese ataque el
ejército israelí arremetió contra un
palestino de 27 años en el pueblo de
azul este es el más reciente suceso en
una ola de violencia en la región veamos
el siguiente informe
enfrentamientos entre palestinos y la
policía israelí en azul se generaron
tras el funeral del joven que murió en
una operación del ejército israelí
realizada luego que dos hombres armados
mataron a un guardia de seguridad en la
entrada de ariel por este último hecho
que se lo atribuyó el grupo militante
palestino vinculado a al fatah la
brigada de los mártires de al-aqsa las
fuerzas de seguridad israelíes
realizaron detenciones e incautaron
armas estas acciones forman parte de una
creciente violencia entre israelíes y
palestinos en las últimas semanas en
medio de un aumento de las tensiones en
torno al complejo de la mezquita de al
aqsa en jerusalén este el tercer lugar
más sagrado del islám se encuentra en el
monte del templo el lugar más venerado
del judaísmo israel se anexionó
jerusalén del este junto con cisjordania
tras la guerra de los seis días de 1967
en una medida no reconocida por la
comunidad internacional además impuso
restricciones que hacen prácticamente
imposible que la mayoría de los
palestinos recen en la mezquita este mes
se han generado múltiples
enfrentamientos en el recinto al
coincidir la celebración musulmana con
la pascua judía
queremos visitar la mezquita de al-aqsa
y rezar dentro porque hacerlo triplica
la recompensa
los ocupantes son responsables de la
agresión que está ocurriendo aquí
hace casi un año un desalojo de familias
palestinas de jerusalén éste provocó una
guerra de 11 días que terminó con un
acuerdo de alto el fuego entre israel y
hamás el grupo militante que gobierna
gaza los palestinos reclaman jerusalén
este como capital de su futuro estado
israel la llama su capital eterna desde
china celebra su fiesta nacional del
primero de mayo en medio de un aumento
de los contagios de kobe 19 las nuevas
restricciones enmarcadas en la política
de kobe cero que maneja el país marcan
esta celebración del día internacional
de los trabajadores más en el siguiente
informe en tiempos normales las calles
de beijing estarían llenas de gente para
la fiesta nacional del trabajo pero este
año los lugares públicos se han quedado
casi sin turistas por el temor al
aumento de los contagios por kobe 19 los
negocios han sufrido un duro golpe y
esta vendedora no se siente optimista
las ventas fueron buenas el año pasado
pero este año han sido miserables muchas
de las autoridades locales en diferentes
partes del territorio chino están
pidiendo a los residentes que limiten
los viajes por el país china mantiene su
política de kobe cero y con la última
oleada de la variante omicron decenas de
ciudades del país están bajo bloqueo
total o parcial la propia capital ha
implementado nuevas restricciones a
pesar de sólo registrar unas pocas
docenas de casos al día los restaurantes
permanecen cerrados mientras que los
parques temas y los lugares de ocio
están a la mitad de su capacidad beijing
quiere evitar un cierre total como el de
shanghai mediante una campaña de pruebas
masivas la mayor parte de los 25
millones de residentes del centro
económico llevan ya más de un mes
confinados en sus casas lo que ha
provocado protestas en parte de la
población la ciudad registró 10.000
casos el viernes pero por primera vez no
hubo nuevos contagios fuera del sistema
de cuarentena es probable que las
últimas restricciones supongan un nuevo
golpe para la economía del país y varios
detenidos en ecuador durante el primer
día del estado de excepción decretado
por el presidente guillermo lasso en
tres provincias de la costa del país el
mandatario decretó la medida para las
regiones costeras de guayas manabí y
esmeraldas esta es la segunda vez que
utiliza poderes de emergencia para
contrarrestar la violencia que está
disparada desde el año pasado y que está
vinculada con las bandas de narcotráfico
nuestro corresponsal gustavo ortega
tiene más detalles
en el marco de la primera jornada del
estado de sección la policía nacional
capturó a 14 personas relacionadas a
organizaciones criminales acusados de
asesinato o porte ilegal de armas y
tráfico de drogas según declaraciones de
la policía nacional luego de seis meses
de operaciones de inteligencia aseguró a
la policía nacional en las horas más
peligrosas del país conformada por
guayaquil durán y samborondón banega
diario tres personas por día en hechos
de violencia según cifras oficiales en
lo que va de año se registran 445
asesinatos tan sólo en esta zona casi el
doble lo registrado en el año anterior
el ejecutivo decretó un estado de
sección que se extenderá durante 60 días
y ha movilizado a 9 mil efectivos en
tres fuerzas armadas y policías en las
calles los ciudadanos reciben este
estado de decisión que una espectativa y
temor la violencia estaba asociada a las
disputas entre organizaciones por el
control del territorio y el tráfico de
drogas la iglesia católica ha expresado
su preocupación por los altos índices de
pobreza y violencia y criminalidad
creciente en el país a la par el
debilitado sistema carcelario también le
pasa factura del estado previamente el
departamento de estado de los eeuu había
alertado sus ciudadanos de no viajar a
las localidades de carchi esmeraldas
sucumbíos y al suroeste de la ciudad de
guayaquil debido a la delincuencia
hasta aquí este repaso informativo sigan
conectados a france 24 y france 24
puntocom
[Música]